this morning as we continue our focus on
the most interesting new books robert e
lee and me the author is former army
brigadier general ty sigily who served
his country for more than 30 years
he retired last year he says so he could
finally speak his mind in full
his book is a searing attack not just on
his upbringing
but on some ugly parts of america that
endure
you feel the history here oh there is so
much history starting with george
washington
growing up ty sigily says all he wanted
to be
was a southern gentleman his hero a top
graduate
of the u.s military academy former
superintendent
at west point and the commander of the
confederate army
robert e lee when you grew up you said
you held robert e lee as an 11
on a scale of 1-10 and jesus jesus was a
five
that's something yes so on a scale of
one to ten
uh that lee was the greatest not only
the greatest general that ever lived but
the greatest human being
and everything i had around me growing
up in alexandria virginia
uh made me think that and so what
changed all that
here living at west point after
attending washington and lee university
named for both george washington and lee
sigily served in the army
in kosovo saudi arabia and iraq just to
name a few
before becoming a history professor at
west point i lived in lee road
in le housing area uh by league and i
was walking one day
uh at by lee barracks and i just stopped
and i just
looked at that sign and looked at that
sign and then i looked east
about 20 yards they had a new statue of
lee there and i just wondered
why west point had all these things
named after lee i understood washington
lee i didn't understand that
and that started it and then i went into
the archives
the result of that work his new book
robert e lee and me
a southerner's reckoning with the myth
of the lost cause
the lost cause is a 150 year old
ideology that advances the belief that
the confederate cause was just and
heroic
it has long been symbolized by lee he
was a cruel enslaver someone who
believed deeply
firmly and really his entire life that
human enslavement was the best
best social system for the south one of
the reasons some people
still celebrate robert e lee is because
they felt like he was
a brilliant tactician and a good
military strategist
you disagree with that he's a loser he
lost
we americans like like winners so one he
lost
two the cause which he fought for could
you imagine
jeff what this country would look like
if they had won we would have had a
disastrous future
so what are we looking at here right now
this is buffalo soldier field it used to
be
cavalry parade field until the early
1970s when
black cadets forced the academy to
change
where's lee barracks lee barracks is
that way
about a half mile i think what might
surprise a lot of people is that all
these things
named after lee here at west point
it happened when integration was going
on it happened
in the 1900s in fact the first thing
named after lee is really 1930s
and the first african-american to come
back to west point in the 20th century
as a cadet
comes in the 1930s and there's a
portrait of him in confederate
gray that's put up in 1950 152
and that's a reaction to the army's
integration six years ago sigily posted
a short online video about why this
civil war was fought
it has since received more than 34
million views
the south was preoccupied with states
rights because it was preoccupied first
and foremost with retaining slavery
thank you for the invitation he followed
that video up by returning to his alma
mater at washington and lee
and double down in this 2017 speech
look at your left look at your right
lots of folks are uncomfortable
i'm uncomfortable telling the truth is a
ruthless act
was it odd giving that talk oh gosh
terrifying
terrifying i was going to call robert e
lee a traitor for slavery
standing on top of his grave and behind
me was the recumbent statue of lee and
confederate
regalia really so yeah i was nervous you
had to resign your commission
to be able to write this book and speak
out
the way you are now why did you feel
that was so important well i had to
retire
uh so i had to retire from the army
because i could not
give uh i couldn't be free i mean i
couldn't exercise the first amendment
rights that i'm doing right now
because it was too hot for the army the
army had these 10 bases named after
confederates and it couldn't change them
without our political
uh masters are civilian politicians
telling them they could
and it was just too hot for the army but
those are changing now oh they're
changing
within three years within three years
the national defense authorization act
will ensure that all of those are
changing what else do you think should
happen
beyond that we've got to have truth what
is what does truth mean for you then
besides
changing the name of fort bragg and fort
hood and
the lee monuments here at west point
what does that truth mean
well i think we've got to look at in the
army um
promotion rates the percentage of black
cadets is more than reflective of
society
but the number of black general officers
is far from it
images from the capital this month show
that the confederacy's lost cause
has not been abandoned by all but sigily
feels
he is making progress
including in some unlikely places
in the end of all of this when you
finished speaking you got a standing
ovation
i got standing ovation at w at
washington university for calling leah
trader for slavery
for telling my school to do more to
engage with the lost cause myth
to end their white supremacy to be more
to be more just
and to lead the way and they they
embraced me i tell you i felt this warm
glow of acceptance
you know but as we all know one speech
doesn't change
society and doesn't change a college
what does
uh work hard work lots of it
over and over and over again so the
latest defense bill has these ten base
names changing and also these uh
memorials and commemorations at west
point within three years
um sigil is hoping that at west point in
particular the names change
within a year and not enough for years
telling
the truth is a ruthless act i mean bravo
i have told you over and over and over
again the messenger matters is people
like him
who have a voice who have a perspective
coming from him
there's no better person a southerner
who's in the military jeff